До Німеччини від початку війни прибуло понад 360 тисяч українців.
Німецька держава пропонує їм соціальний захист, а також право на роботу.
DW зібрала найважливіше про працевлаштування українських біженців у Німеччині.
Дозвіл на роботу українці отримують автоматично з тимчасовим дозволом на проживання в Німеччині,
який видають у відомстві у справах іноземців.
Тимчасовий документ, а пізніше посвідка на проживання має містити запис "Працевлаштування дозволено".
Маючи такий документ, українці можуть офіційно шукати роботу в Німеччині.
Також можна відкрити власний бізнес або працювати як фрілансер.
Щоправда, відкрити власну справу у Німеччині бюрократично складно -
потрібно враховувати німецькі вимоги до відкриття бізнесу:
правові врегулювання, особливі дозволи або питання пов’язані із страхуванням.
Федеральне агентство зайнятості допомагає знайти роботу мешканцям Німеччини.
Це державна установа, її послуги безкоштовні.
На сайті установи вже можна знайти інформацію українською мовою з питань пошуку роботи,
здобуття професійної освіти, підвищення кваліфікації або перекваліфікації,
визнання дипломів або вивчення німецької мови.
Роботу також можна знайти самостійно через знайомих або на сайтах пошуку вакансій.
Останнім часом з'явилося багато приватних ініціатив, які спрямовані на те,
щоб біженці з України могли знайти роботу.
Такі інтернет-ресурси як UATalents або Imagine Ukraine пропонують українцям робочі місця.
Знання німецької є вагомим фактором не лише для пошуку роботи,
але й просто для комфортності життя у Німеччині.
Агентства зайнятості та відомства з питань міграції пропонують безкоштовні курси німецької для українців.
Після проходження базового інтеграційного курсу володіння німецькою мовою має бути на рівні B1.
Після цього можна записатися і на спеціалізований мовний курс - приміром, для лікарів.
Альтернативним варіантом для вивчення мови для дорослих
є курси в так званих народних вищих школах - Volkshochschule.
Мовні курси пропонують також різні католицькі організації.
Варто додати, що часом для працевлаштування - залежно від виду роботи -
не висувають обов'язкової вимоги щодо німецької - нерідко достатньо лише володіння англійсьою.
Середній рівень заробітної плати в Німеччині відрізняється залежно від федеральної землі
- у східних землях зарплати нижчі. У Німеччині є законодавчо закріплена мінімальна заробітна плата.
Її сума на даний момент складає 9,82 євро в годину.
З 1 липня цього року ця сума зросте до 10,45 євро,
а з жовтня планується подальше підвищення до 12 євро на годину.
Слід враховувати, що ці погодинні ставки без урахування податків та інших соціальних відрахувань,
які може сягати до 40% доходу.
Робочий час загалом не має перевищувати вісім годин на день.
Слід бути пильними з недобросовісними працедавцями або надто приманливими обіцянками,
аби не стати жертвою шахраїв. Варто уникати "чорної" роботи,
оскільки це в Німеччині карається чималими штрафами.
Інформацію про права як найнятого працівника в Німеччині можна знайти сайті Faire Integration.
Якщо є конкретні проблеми, приміром, є підозра, що роботодавець платить замало,
консультаційні центри нададуть вам інформацію, зокрема українською, російською або англійською мовами.
Визнання вашої професійної кваліфікації є обов’язковим, якщо ви хочете працювати
у сфері так званих регламентованих професій, наприклад, лікарем або вчителем.
У нерегламентованих професіях - приміром, хіміком чи продавцем - визнання дипломів не обов'язкове,
але це значно збільшує шанси знайти роботу, яка відповідає саме вашій кваліфікації.
Швидше і легше працевлаштуватися за профтехнічною спеціальністю - доглядальниці, водія, швачки, сантехніка.
У Німеччині нестача робочих рук в багатьох робітничих професіях.
Деякі компанії навіть стартували спеціальні програми для українців.
Так, наприклад, концерн Deutsche Bahn націлено шукає машиністів і машиністок з України і
навіть організував гарячу лінію українською та російською мовами для тих,
хто хоче знайти роботу на німецькій залізниці.
Чим вищий рівень кваліфікації робітника, тим довше може тривати пошук роботи.
Тут і вимоги вищі і зазвичай необхідні також знання німецької.
Винятком може бути професія вчителя.
Оскільки в Німеччину приїхало багато українських дітей, у деяких землях для них влаштовують
спеціальні підготовчі класи, у яких відповідно працевлаштовують вчителів з України.
Важливий аспект: слід добре зважити, скільки грошей "чистими" - тобто після усіх відрахувань - ви зароблятимете.
Адже якщо ви працевлаштуєтеся, то втратите право на отримання соціальної допомоги.
З червня розмір місячної допомоги зросте до 400-450 євро на дорослого
та від 285  до 376 євро на дитину залежно від віку.
Додатковим фактором, який заважає повноцінному працевлаштуванню, є проблема догляду за дІтьми.
У Німеччині і без того дефіцит місць у садочках або в групах продовженого дня у школах.
А з прибуттям великої кількості дітей з України, ця проблема лише загостриться.